we're going to begin this NewsHour in
Sudan where there's been no let up in
the fighting between the Army and para
military rapid support forces as they
battle for control of crucial areas in
Khartoum this is despite indirect talks
happening in Saudi Arabia but neither
side appears willing to back down felia
Carr begins our coverage
[Music]
Army Chief Abdul fatah al-braham
inspecting troops at the headquarters in
cartoon
[Music]
it's a rare public appearance for the
general his third since fighting between
the Army and paramilitary Rapid support
forces began in mid-april the battle for
controller Sudan shows no sign of ending
[Applause]
on Wednesday Army supporters
demonstrated in Port Sudan they're
demanding United Nations Envoy Volker
parathas leave accusing him of
interference
[Applause]
we demand that Volker the UNM boy be
removed from his position he is
responsible for the conflict because he
has contributed to the division and
separation of the people in this country
both the Army and Rapid support forces
have claimed control of strategic sites
in cartoon this week
[Music]
and both insist they have the upper hand
the two have been holding indirect talks
in Jeddah since the beginning of the
month but they fail to agree on a
permanent resolution a series of
ceasefires have failed
gives a statement that the truce will be
from this hour to that hour the
continued Air Raids and artillery fire
is proof that there is more than one
decision maker in this crisis and it's
one of the reasons that the hostilities
don't end it proves the lack of Will
from the Sudanese Army
more styled negotiations means more
uncertainty and more hardship and
suffering people are leaving cartoon
because there's no food no water no
electricity and there is very high
levels of insecurity wfp is providing
hot meals wfp will continue to support
refugees as and when they arrive for the
future is very Bleak for those people it
is Bleak for Sudan and it is Bleak for
the region
more than a month into the conflict the
UN says one million people have been
displaced they can't go home until the
two sides agree to stop fighting Freddie
acar Al Jazeera
Tampa Morgan is joining us live from
Ultraman what's the latest on the
fighting in Khartoum and the surrounding
areas
it's launched by the Sudanese Army
against several supposed positions of
the rapid support forces now it started
in the early hours of Thursday here in
the city of umdurman around an area
known as Kerri which is not far from the
military Air Base where the fighter jets
that have been targeting the positions
of the rapid support forces have been
taking off from now the Army says that
they know that the rsf has been trying
to Target that base to neutralize its
Air Force but they say that they're
putting their defenses around that area
to ensure that their air base is
protected there's also been airstrikes
in the Northern parts of the capital
Khartoum in the city of bahri and that's
because of the heavy presence of the
rapid support forces troops in that City
we also spoke to Residents in the
southern part of the capital krotom and
they say that the rapid support forces
attacked the central Reserve police now
these are the militarized unit of the
police and the residents in that area
say that the rsf were pushed back and
that several of their technicals were
captured by the central Reserve police
so it looks like on the ground fighting
is continuing despite the fact that the
two sides are holding talks in Japan
Saudi Arabia to try to work out a
ceasefire yeah happy I want to ask you
about those talks because they are
indirect talks the two sides aren't
speaking um face to face as it were do
we know what's happening with those
negotiations
well both Saudi Arabia and the United
States who are mediating these talks are
these indirect talks between the rapid
support forces and the Sudanese Army are
trying to get the two sides to agree on
one basic thing which is a ceasefire for
humanitarian Aid to be able to come into
Khartoum for those who are in need as
well as for civilians who are trapped in
the capital unable to leave because of
the ongoing fighting to be able to make
it to safer zones so far the two sides
cannot agree on a ceasefire we also
heard from the advisor of the rapid
support forces commander in the South
Sudanese Capital Juba talking about the
ceasefire saying that he his Commander
General Muhammad is ready to speak to
the Army Commander General Abdul Fateh
al-bruhan to reach some kind of an
agreement but that has to start with a
ceasefire on the ground and so far
that's one thing that's the main thing
that the two sides cannot agree upon
they cannot agree upon a mechanism to
enforce that ceasefire especially when
several ceasefires have been violated
before they cannot agree on a mechanism
to ensure that humanitarian Aid is
delivered to the people here in the
capital of and other parts of the
country and they are holding indirect
talks mediators trying to get the two
sides to reach some kind of consensus
but so far that's proving challenging
Heather Morgan in onderman Heber thank
you very much
well the conflict's been forcing
Sudanese people out of their homes for
decades refugees from previous Wars who
settled in neighboring Chad and now
welcoming the latest wave of people
fleeing the fighting zimbusravi has more
from boruto camp in eastern Chad
the best way to understand how bad the
conflict is in Sudan is perhaps to hear
directly from refugees
many people have lost their lives today
al-janaina has been transformed into
hell I want the United Nations to
intervene we don't live like people
we're not eating properly we don't have
health services we can't bear any more
of this
Mustafa a teacher says his country is no
longer a functioning State at the borata
displacement camp in Chad one after
another Refugee gives accounts of
running away from large groups of armed
men who roamed the countryside
terrorizing civilians most here are
women and children particularly
vulnerable to kidnapping and sexual
violence
the war is really bad a child silvering
breastfed can be killed alongside his
mother his father can be killed there is
nothing good about war
witness to death they arrive traumatized
especially the youngest
we have to move them from the border
area to the safer place as well as we
have to move them where they can have
older older assistant and services such
as a school that a lot of parents
mention about that that they want to
send their children to schools as well
as health services that they can access
Aid groups say it's a Race Against Time
Reigns will come the camp will flood and
this remote area will become
inaccessible we were here just a few
days ago and there are already signs
that this Camp is getting bigger and
people are adapting to their
circumstances this is a makeshift Market
right in the middle of this dry riverbed
you can buy food
shoes fruits flashlights charge your
cell phone you can get soaps and
biscuits really anything people might
immediately need the other sign that
this Camp is changing that it's getting
bigger is that there are now makeshift
tents on both banks of the river
attempting to bring order to the chaos
the UN has started relocating people
at a camp in Gaga the newly arrived are
welcomed by Neighbors in a unique
position to empathize
Sudanese displaced from the same
Villages by the war in Darfur in 2003.
perhaps finding some Solace and seeing
life goes on living without fear of
attack is possible and children can go
back to school
something that will come as a comfort to
one teacher with a message to the
warring sides in Khartoum
what you are doing has killed thousands
he says silence the guns
stop the war
Zain Bas Ravi Al Jazeera borota Eastern
Chad